Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P, I think this is the
friendly. This is a voicemail that is praising me.
I don't think we've ever had a voicemail with this
much praise that needed this many bleeps. We've
gotten a lot of hate messages that need bleeps,
but never praise that needs this
many bleeps. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 5: Hey, David, this is Lamar's other
listeners for a minute now. Yeah, I'm from Philly.
So low minutes just means a long period of time
where I don't know why we do that, but that's just
something we do. Anyway, I just wanted to say I
think you actually doing great. You're doing God's
work for Oprah. If I was to tell you the truth,
Mike, I think you are here doing God's work.
But what I don't like about this show, and this is
not a not for you at all, is there are people that
come in calling things not even watching all of
your cards. Like, you could tell that they don't
watch it and they just wanted to call it a hurrahs
you like at least on call in their careers to
uplifting you think about it you know calling they
just harangues you to be like, Oh, that's weird.
But anyway, I think the show is great. I think
you're doing a phenomenal job and I want you to
keep it up. All right. Thank you. Have a good one.
Speaker 1: Well, I appreciate the praise. Really
putting Pat to work. They're making this radio
an FCC friendly for hour radio broadcast. Here
is what I would say about this. I agree completely
that there is something really sad and depressing
about people who spend so much time writing me
these long hate emails or leaving me these long
hate voicemails, not only in reaction to things
I've said, but barely paying attention to things
that I've actually said. And as you know, we
have a lot of different trolls and people who
call in and they attack me for things I have not
actually said. And what I go back to is I actually
feel bad for them. You know, sometimes I'll get
one of these messages and I go, Oh, that really
bothers me. And then I'll say, Wait a second. How
sad of a life must someone have that they go, Hey,
you know what? I think I'm going to get my phone
out and leave three, three minute voicemails,
swearing and making a fool out of myself for
someone I don't even know. And I realize they
must lead truly sad and depressing lives and
I end up feeling bad for them. And I think
the caller makes that point very, very well.
We have a great bonus show for you today. We
are going to talk about a video that appears to
show another one of these people trying to pass
bills against drag dressed in drag. This one
is from Texas. The last one was from Tennessee.
This one is from Texas. Secondly, Kari Lake, not
Nikki Haley, won the CPAC vice presidential poll,
topping Ron DeSantis topping Nikki Haley. It is
another sign that CPAC is still full MAGA. And
then thirdly, former Maryland Republican Governor
Larry Hogan says he will not be challenging Donald
Trump in the 2024 primary. Fine, not a big
deal, but his reasons as to why are super,
super interesting. Sign up at join Packman dot
com to get access to those discussions on the
bonus show. You can use the coupon code. 24 starts
now. All one word, all lowercase. This is the best
way you can support the work we do. Join pacman
dot com. Coupon code 24 starts now. Remember,
make your voice heard for free. By making
sure you subscribe to our YouTube channel at
YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show like
our videos, leave a comment. And also, don't
forget that much of our content now available in
Spanish at David Pakman dot com slash Spanish.
See you on the bonus show. It's just the
beginning of a great week of programs for you.